we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p i was thrilled to hear that
a former president bill clinton called
in who was apparently a big fan of the
show take a listen to this hey David
it's Bill Clinton former President Bill
Clinton I just wanted to call and say
great job love your show
keep up the good work wish I could say
that Hillary and I watch it together but
well you know that beat be a bit of a
lie and I don't tell lies though I'm
telling you the truth I love your show I
think you great job and uh up there more
young man out there inspired by you and
the work that you do okay take care
all right always great to hear from the
former president and hope to hear from
him again on the bonus show today tech
giants file a legal challenge to Donald
Trump's daca assault Donald Trump jr.
sends out Halloween tweets about
socialism and gets absolutely destroyed
and also I will talk about New York
banning salary questions to fight the
gender pay gap fascinating bonus show
today two ways to access at david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show and remember we
now accept cryptocurrency read about it
get our wallet addresses at david
pakman.com slash cryptocurrency speak to
you on the bonus show